so tonight anderson sent to work to san
diego trent grisham will lead it off
and a little dribbler off the end of the
bat takes a little tough hop off that
grass but philip evans quick
moves to his left and not
track available machado flies out to
deep right center
another one off the end of the bat and
they have evans played perfectly wow
what a difference a knight makes
he's throwing all striker he throws all
strikes joe musgrove in his first start
since the no-hitter comes in at 2-0 mud
for his third start there's a lot going
on here he threw the no hitter of course
now he's pitching in a place where he
pissed for a few seasons a mount he is
very familiar with
on the ground down the first baseline
hosmer to musgrove and the throws a
little high and a nice athletic play by
musgrove to cover the bag there for the
first out they've been sitting at 382 so
far in the year and he grounds this one
to shortstop hassan kim
two down
he got the rally started with two outs
yesterday and there's a fly ball to
shallow left field and that's gonna drop
in and you can all kind of breeze
breathe easy now get it out of the way
well there goes the no hitter donny not
to be
on the corner for strike three musgrove
wins the battle and that will wrap up
the first inning without a score from
pittsburgh
2-2 home
oh swinging
struck him
dropped down from the side too he did he
dropped down a little bit fastball
running in on him and
we finally saw a swing and miss out of
cronenworth
this one is line to left and it's in for
a base hit in front of reynolds
profile stop at second base and the
padres have something going here with
two down
bounce to the shortstop
and that's newman to frazier
a couple of men left on base
nothing nothing love to see the pirates
up there ready to swing polanco
can talk about back clear the deck with
a cannonball
el cafe
decides his first cup of coffee of the
season will come against joe mustro
that's a nice couple days off that
worked to perfection
swinging a miss and he's able to bounce
back to strike out fowler second k from
musgrove two down
it was the slider to get him and that's
the third strikeout for muskrobe but a
home run for gregory polanco he's won
nothing pirates
this is on the ground up the middle and
it's picked by the shortstop newman who
spins and his throw is off the glove but
moran a screw of gotta get back to the
bag at first and he does
bouncing ball could be two we're going
to run toward musgrove and the throw
gets him at first
well musgrove
tried to avoid the tag but it's a double
play and well done by kevin newman
the other way and frazier has himself a
hit
he will head to second and he will stand
with a double
that's his style right there
swinging a miss and down to one knee
goes evans to strikeout fourth strikeout
for joe musgrove one down well joe does
a nice job of going back to that slider
of his
musgrove says say it isn't so
swinging a miss and he strikes him out
back-to-back case for joe musgrove two
down in the third inning
this is lying towards the gap and right
center field gets out there in a hurry
and one hops the wall
hosmer is headed for two and he will
cruise into second base
with a ringing double up the alley in
right center
popped it up
and playable for phillip evans in foul
ground
and anderson does what musgrove did lead
off double doesn't move them pitchers
dual one nothing
then ball four
first walk of the early season for kevin
newman and it comes against a control
guy in moscow we're there see we are
there that's our booth
and we are there those are actual sizes
yeah yeah those are to scale it is yeah
right size heads it's dawn and mudley
it's awesome
chopped off the tip of the glove in the
right field hosmer doesn't come up with
it cleanly
and it's first and third with no one out
nice ground ball here for two would be
nice
[Applause]
how about a strikeout sure how about a
fresca that is the sixth strikeout for
muskraw of two down in the fourth inning
he goes up the ladder to get perez for
the swing and miss and now an o2 pitch
coming to anderson
and ground ball to shortstop kim's got
it
and that will end the inning as the
pirates will strand two will take us to
the fifth one nothing buckos that's a
big question that they might have the
horses to play with them ball carries
out to reynolds nice play
two outs
and with one out rebels is not as deep
no two outs that's when he has to back
up so he can come in and make this nice
play on the sinking line drive
got him
big punch out for tyler anderson five
shutout frames
one nothing pirates
and lying to right field for frasier up
against the wall he will lead off the
inning with a double well now two outs
and colin moran will try to cash in the
pirates lead off double
and moran delivers
will you pick up your kick mate two
nothing this time moran who has a lot of
extended bats wastes no time
his eighth ribby scores frazier
two-nothing pirates
there's ball four and a walk starts
things in the sixth inning for the
padres a second walk given up by
anderson underwood's had a nice start to
the year so far he inherits a runner on
second one out tommy fan walked in
grounded out to third base there's a one
and two and pham lines this one into
right center field to base hit manny is
it third man he is rounding third man he
will come in to score rbi single tommy
pham now a two to one game in the sixth
and a lion drive
back
to howard
one two three
[Music]
for sling and sammy
[Music]
and the polanco on base for a fourth
time
off the glove of hosmer
so fowler will hold it first polanco to
third it's first and third and would
look like a double play possibility
now gives the pirates a chance to score
that insurance run
oh and he's hit to load them up
gonzalez six for 17 in his career with
the bases loaded
goes the other way shallow right and it
drops
base hit this will score a couple into
second base
gonzalez a little player polanco scores
fowler to third it's three to one
and frazier trying to put this one away
the other way with a base hit
scores another core waving home a second
run and the ball is cut off so perez
will score
on the two run single by frazier
there you go 5-1
rodentwood chops it towards short there
is one there is two and that's two
straight and raise the jolly roger
for a second straight night over the
padres
yeah this was an
excellent game by the pirates they
played it very well tonight